[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين افادت وكاله واسجد بريست عن
وقوع هجوم من بطائره مسيره مفخخه استهدف
ناقله للنفط قباله سواحل عمان وقللا
المتحدث باسم الاسطول الامريكيه الخامس
ان الاسطول على علم بالحادث الذي تعرضت له
سفينه تجاريه في خليج عمان
وظهرت بيانات الملاحيه السفينه المستهدفه
حيث كانت تبحر قباله سواحل عمان منذ 13
ساعه
وترفع على ملينه وقد اتهم مسؤولنا منيو
اسرائيلي كبير ايران بالوقوف وراء الهجوم
بحسب ما نقلته اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
فقدت الشركه المشغل للسفينه انها تحقق في
الحادثه موضحه لان السفينه كانت تحمل شحنه
من الغاز وقد اصيبت بقذفه على بعد 150
ميلا تقريبا قبال ساحل عمان
وقالت انه لا تقارير عن اصابات بين افراد
طاقه من السفينه لكن الهجوم خلف بعض
الاضرار طفيفه لاحقه بدني السفينه
من مسقط الان من جديد نرحب به سمير النمري
مراسل الجزيره سمير مرحبا بك اخر
المعلومات حول هذه الناقله وتواجدها اماكن
المكان استهدافها تحديدا
نعم محمد لم يصدر حتى هذه اللحظات اي بيان
رسمي هنا من السلطات العمانيه ولكن بحسب
بيانات المصادر الرادار الملاحه البحريه
فان السفينه تعرضت للهجوم على منطقه في
منطقه بعيده جدا من السواحل العمانيه
وتحديدا في منطقه همم تفصل بين بحر عمان
وبحر العرب في المياه الدوليه هذه
البيانات تؤكد ان الاستهداف تم بعد خروج
السفينه من المياه الاقليميه العمانيه
ووصولها الى المياه الدوليه وربما هذا
الاستهداف كان قريبا جدا من مكان
الاستهداف الذي تعرضت له سفينه همم سفينه
نفطيه تابعه لشركه اسرائيليه في يوليو من
العام همم الماضي بيانات الملاحيه همم
التي نشرتها هذه المواقع تشير الى هذه
السفيره كانت قادمه من ميناء صحار
العمانيه عند وغادرت هذا الميناء عند
الساعه
1:50 دقيقه ظهرا همم من يوم امس واستهدفت
في مساء يوم امس ايضا بعد ان تجاوزت
المياه الاقليميه العمانيه ووصلت الى
المياه الدوليه كانت السفينه التي تعرضت
للاستهداف سابق في العمل الماضي في تلك
المنطقه واعلن السلطنه عمان حينها ان
الاستهداف تم في المياه الاقليميه في
المياه الدوليه وليس في المياه الاقليميه
العمانيه وهما يعني ان هذا الاستهداف
يحاول تجنب ان تكون سلطنه عمان داخله في
هذا الصراع التي الذي ربما تكون اطرافه هي
من تصدر الاتهامات وهي اا ايران واسرائيل
نحن بالطبع سنه خلال الساعات القادمه ربما
يصدر ايام توضيحي من السلطات العمانيه
لتوضيح ما حدث بالفعل ولان ايران مشتبه
بها من قبل اسرائيل نتحول الان الى
مراسلين نور الدين غير من طهران وهل صدر
اي موقف او تصريح رسمي من هناك
المواقف اذا ما قلنا بان الحروب القائمه
بين ايران واسرائيل يمكن التصنيفها بانها
حروب في الظل فبالتالي لا تكون هناك اي
تبني لاي عمل حتى من الجانب الاسرائيلي
لما كان يستهدف السفن الايرانيه في البحر
الاحمر وفي المحيط البحر الابيض المتوسط
والبحر الاحمر لم تكون هناك لم يكن هناك
تبني واضح وصريح لاستهداف وانما هي
استنتاجات مبنيه على مجموعه من القرائن
على الارض حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد هناك اي
موقف ايراني يتبنى خاصه حينما نتحدث عن
الموقف الايراني يتحدث عن الموقف العسكري
المرتبط بالجهه التي فعلا لديها القوه على
امتلاك طائره مسيره وهي الحرس الثوري
الايراني بشكل كبير لان همم الخليجيه لحد
الساعه ليس هناك اي موقف من الحرس الدوري
الايراني او من القوات البحريه الحرس
المرابطه على مستوى المياه همم الخليجيه
الى
ديقه هرمز لكن بكل تاكيد هناك الكثير من
القراءات والكثير من التساؤلات تطرح حول
هذه العمليه هل هي امتداد لحرب السفن التي
انطلقت منذ سنتين تقريبا ما بين ايران
واسرائيل وهل هناك مستجد حدث ربما ليدفع
اسرائيل القيام بهذه العمل او ان هذه
العمليه ربما باعتبار انها تمت بطائره
مسيره مفخخه يمكن ان تكون منطلقها مكان
اخر غير الاراضي الايرانيه وغير قوات
الايرانيه وكما اسرت سابقا هناك مجموعه من
المناطق همم يمكن ان تدخل ضمن هذه العمليه
هناك الحوثيون في اليمن وهناك الجماعات
والمجموعات المسلحه في العراق والتي اثبتت
انها تمتلك هذه المسيرات وقادره على قطع
هذه المسافات لاستهداف اهداف داخل المياه
وربما حتى اهداف داخل المحيط الهندي
وداخله البحر الاحمر لكن العديد من القائد
ربما قد تدفع بشكل او باخر لنقول بانه قد
تكون نوعا ما عمليه انتقاميه هناك مواقف
وتصريحات من الجانب الايراني حينما رات
ايران بانها مستت في امنها القوم سواء في
الحدود الشماليه الغربيه ونتحدث عن
المناطق الكردستانيه والتي شهدت قبل ايام
ومنذ مده هجوم للحرس الثوري على مواقع
للمعارضه الكرديه وكذلك تحرك بما قد يصنف
على انه الانف على مستوى الاحتجاجات في
هذه المنطقه واتهام ايران الصريح لاسرائيل
دكتور في الاحتجاجات القائمه بايران قبل
قليل وقبل هذا المباشر بدات القنوات
الاعلاميه هنا المواقع الاعلاميه تبد
تصريح لما سمي بعميم للمصاد كان هنا في
ايران لتحريك الاحتجاجات ولتحريك
التظاهرات
الامن القومي الايراني وكذلك العمليات
التي تقوم بها المعارضه الكرديه تدخل في
هذا التصنيف الايراني باعتبار ان هذه
المجموعات تصنف ايرانيين على انها مدعومه
من الخارج واسرائيل احدى هذه الاطراف هل
يمكن ان يكون ان تكون هذه المعطيات وهذه
المستجدات الداخليه في ايران ان تكون مبنى
اساسي يبنى عليه بان تتهم ايران ربما قد
يبقى هذا سؤال مطروح في غياب اي معطيات
حقيقيه في غياب اي معطيات واضحه على مستوى
القرائن وعلى مستوى الشواهد والادله بان
ايران هي المتهمه بكل تاكيد لا يمكن اخراج
ما يحدث الان في المنطقه هو ضمن الصراع
القائم الان ما بين ايران وما بين اسرائيل
وما بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكثير
من المرات كانت ايران استهدفت في امنها
القومي فانها مستعده على الرد على هذه
الجهات في همم الاماكن التي تتواجد فيها
لذلك لا يمكن الان الحديث هل الايران
المتورده ام غير متورطه في انتظار القرائن
والادله التي يمكن ان تكشف عنها الجهات
المعنيه
[موسيقى]